[Musique]
le président du département s'est rendu
à l'atelier défi pour rencontrer les
acteurs de la filière de transformation
du bois de goyavier ici une quarantaine
d'agents façonne et réalise des objets à
partir de ses gaules est récolté dans
les forêts des portemanteaux de manière
je vais à la rencontre des agents du
département et ce matin effectivement je
suis ici dans cage au sein de la filière
bois de goyavier avec les agents du
département qui travaillent ce bois
magnifique et le bois de goyavier on a
fait d'une peste végétale un produit
remarquable à produits mobiliers
remarquable
je salue le travail réalisé ici que nos
ateliers fonctionnent bien
j'ai vu des ouvriers efficace le bois de
goyavier représente une véritable
filière d'exploitation chaque année 200
milles gaulle est de cette peste
végétale sont prélevés dans les forêts
par des associations gérées par le nfc
tiges sont ensuite transformés ici et la
production se divise en trois grands
pôles là trois unités
trois unités 1 la première c'est unique
et grands travaux bike et des kiosques
à vocation économique
et autres gros produit autour du
bâtiment et
la charpente ou autre après on a notre
unité
c'est le prototypage autour du mobilier
urbain les bancs les
on va dire dans sa propre elle bacs à
fleurs que
abribus voilà et la dernière unité c'est
un petit miracle tours 2
doublement des projets de développement
sont nombreux comme les kiosques à
vocation économique
le mobilier urbain des roulottes
d'activité et l'aménagement du futur
café des arts au village corail une
filière qui depuis cette année mène une
politique d'insertion avec la formation
de contrats aidés dans l'apprentissage
de la menuiserie ont fait des
réalisations de lemond les tabourets
d'échelle
[Musique]
des trottoirs
mohammad les serviettes le dessus tout
ce qui dit le bois bouger
[Musique]
je